[Music]
so the question is how do you want to
feel I've become really interested
recently in this idea of mediating
experience okay of directly engaging the
technical material of subjectivity
itself of employing technologies of
rhetoric like language songs
storytelling cinema to capture and
control attention and thrust one's
subjectivity into a state of deep
immersion absorption a necessary
precursor for any kind of interpersonal
persuasion or transformation or
education to take place within one's
sight Janet Marie will camlet on the
whole of that talks about the fact that
as narrative beings we long to be
immersed we logged merge with the
narrative to obliterate all sense of
separation to be enveloped in the
mediated environment the story world we
want to disappear and come out on the
other side and she says so powerful is
our desire to be immersed that it's not
just that we suspend disbelief but that
we actively create belief using our
sophisticated intelligence to reinforce
our belief in the story world rather
than to questioning we active
metabolise belief and story knowing this
then the challenge for the artist as it
constructs the cultural technologies of
the 21st century and our technological
desire to virtualize reality we should
keep in mind that we have this immense
opportunity to artfully and creatively
construct these subjective story worlds
and thus the narratives of the future
have the potential to literally
transform what it means to be human to
employ landscapes of mind and turn
subjective experience into a living
breathing painting awake walking lucid
dream this is our opportunity
[Music]
you